est-ce que la grande question que tout
le monde se pose à 20h20 en direct sur
C8 est-ce que tu la galoche
voilà ça c'est pas pécho du tout non
mais il faut savoir sur Koh-Lanta c'est
impossible de ganache
ça nous vient même pas à l'esprit ah
c'est vraiment je vous jure que c'est la
survie avant tout c'est pas possible non
vraiment je pense que oui vous voulez
pas que je réchauffer sa vie
normalement
c'est pas parce qu'il y a un mec il veut
pas te pécho qui veut pas te pécho mais
j'aime bien vérité je la sensation on
est arrêté la pauvre non mais j'ai
analysé les images avec les équipes
c'est comme c'est une position de couple
ça vous êtes même pas un peu pécho dans
la matière non vraiment pas dans la
bonne humeur j'aimerais aller manger
c'est juste qu'ils avaient froid il y a
pas de couverture bah normal c'est la
survie quoi
[Applaudissements]